(audience cheers)
- What's up!
- You look so good!
- Thank you. Thank you. I feel good.
- Yeah, you should.
Okay. Well, it's great
to see you in person.
- Great to see you too, finally.
- I know, last time I was virtual, right?
- [LL Cool J] I know we've been doing
a lot of Zooms.
- [Kelly] I know!
- [LL Cool J] A lot of
staring at a lot of screens.
- We have real people now, what?
- Real people in the building.
(audience cheers)
- What's up real people?
- So, last time you were here,
you were giving fans
your actual phone number,
just because a lot of
people were having problems
with the pandemic.
- Yeah, yeah.
- What was like, did you get
calls? Did you get texts?
- Oh I got a couple.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- Yeah I got a couple of calls.
You know, talking to people.
I'm talking to people's mothers.
Birthdays, like, you know what I'm saying?
Just, good vibes and energy.
I thought during that
time during the pandemic,
especially when everybody was quarantined,
I just wanted to make myself
a little bit more
available than I usually am
and just kind of share
some love and try to
lift some spirits.
- People are missing
connection, yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah. So that's what
I did. And it went well.
- Okay. I have a question.
How many people asked you out on a date?
Do they call you (Kelly laughing)
- Oh boy.
Oh boy.
- I was like, when you
gave your number out,
I was like, whew, he's
about to get blown up.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
That could go left real quick.
- I know.
- You know, when I look at it that way,
maybe I shouldn't have gave my number out.
You know what I mean?
Thinking about it that way.
- How many women are going
to hit him up being like,
"I'm so lonely. You should
probably come over."
(all laughing)
What's the best part of
interacting with fans
like that, though?
- Just the genuine love,
and just being connected to real people
and not like, always being in that bubble.
The bubble is, you know, no pun intended.
The bubble is a crazy
thing because it's like,
you could get disconnected.
And I wanted to make
sure that I was connected
to real people going through
real life situations.
And so that's what it was about for me,
just being real and authentic.
- And I think that's the thing,
we always hear about the
negative side of social media,
which there is, but there's
a lot of great things.
So I know, real negative
and we get real negative real quick,
but it's a shame because
it's how we abuse it
because I also think
there's a lot of connections
to be made there and
people can feel alone.
So it's kind of a cool thing too,
that you're able to connect
with people like that.
- Yeah I think, look, you know,
there's a time and place for everything,
you know what I'm saying?
But I do think that there
is something to be said for
connecting with real people
and just letting them know that you care,
especially when you're in
a position of influence.
It doesn't matter if every single person
knows everything you did.
When you're in a position of influence
and you have an effect on society,
sometimes you got to step up,
and man up a little bit and just say,
"Hey, I'm here for you
to lift your spirits."
If nothing else, it
ain't a cure for COVID.
But at least it can make people's lives
- Boy, but if you have one,
- a little better.
just share it with the class.
- A thousand percent.
- Wow. It's still happening.
Well, speaking of fans,
so you saw one of my
writers Nick this summer.
So do you remember this?
- [LL Cool J] Yo that's
hilarious. Yo that's real funny.
- [Kelly] That's first of all,
- That's crazy.
- You are in a magical
place. Where are you?
- Yeah. Yeah. That's Portofino, Italy.
- I love Portofino.
- Yeah, yeah that was-
Did you go to, I'm going to say it wrong.
Did you go to, is it Cinque Terre?
How do you say?
- I can't even pronounce that.
- It's the little sad little
villages. I can't either.
I can't either. I wish I
could be sexy right now.
- Yeah I can't
(mispronounces Cinque Terre).
Yeah I don't know.
- I don't how to say it, but it's like,
that's such a beautiful area.
- A lot of fun. Shout
out to Magic Johnson.
We hung out and had a lot of fun.
- [Kelly] That's who you vacation with?
- Yeah.
- That's. Okay. Damn.
I love my friends too. I'm just like, wow.
- Shout out to my man
Magic. It was a lot of fun,
but you know what,
the real thing is about that
fellowship though, right?
Like that was cool. It
was fun. It was nice.
But the fellowship was the thing.
Like being around people
that just believe in winning.
You know, Magic, we had
a lot of conversations
about winning, about success,
about going after your dreams,
about believing in yourself,
believing that you have
the ability to do anything
you put your mind to.
- 100 percent.
- So those were, that was the real thing.
It wasn't really about like,
(makes taunting noises) We were on a boat.
You know what I mean?
It wasn't really about that.
- Yeah but it is nice to be
on a boat sometimes, yeah.
- Yeah, it could be worse.
It could be a lot worse.
- Sometimes it's nice because I find like,
I love water for some reason.
And I'm an earth sign, but
like I love, I feel like water
is just so calming.
- What's your sign?
- Like when you get out
there. I'm a Taurus.
- [LL Cool J] You're a Taurus.
- What's your sign?
- I'm a Capricorn.
- Okay. Oh, y'all are really
easy to get along with.
- We can be.
- Oh, no! (all laughing)